as an immigrant to this country i would
like to say a few words to my fellow
americans
president trump sought to overturn the
results of an election
and of a fair election he saw the coup
by misleading people with lies
that's arnold schwarzenegger speaking
out against president trump
and his involvement in last week's
attack on the capitol
my father and our neighbors were misled
also with lies
and i know where such lies lead
president trump is a failed leader he
will go down in history as the worst
president
ever the good thing is that he soon will
be as irrelevant as an
old tweet it's a surprisingly raw
and candid message from the movie star
and former governor of california
who rarely opens up about his childhood
in
post-world war ii austria
i grew up in austria i'm very aware of
kristallnacht
or the night of broken glass it was a
night of rampage against the jews
carried out in 1938
at the nazi equivalent of the proud boys
wednesday was the day of broken glass
right here in the united states
so being from europe i've seen firsthand
how things can spin out of control
i know there is a fear in this country
and all over the world
that something like this could happen
right here and many celebrities have
applauded arnold's message
duck his true lies co-star jamie lee
curtis tweeted quote
much needed conan o'brien wrote quote
thank you arnold this is the most
powerful
and uniquely personal statement i've
heard from anyone
on where we are right now as a country
both katherine and patrick
schwarzenegger shared emotional pleas
on social media catherine tweeted quote
please watch and listen to this message
we need this patrick wrote quote if you
have a moment
listen to this today so profound really
well said dad
proud of you for using your voice as an
american
republican and immigrant
arnold's emotional message follows one
of the most
chaotic weeks in the country's history
in reaction to president trump's role in
inciting the attack on the capitol
his social media accounts have all been
banned
including twitter facebook and instagram
sadly the person who's running executive
branch
is a deranged unhinged
dangerous president of the united states
and only a number of days until
we can be protected from him but he has
done something
so serious that there should be
prosecution against him
in a preview of her 60 minutes
appearance on sunday
speaker of the house nancy pelosi opens
up about
the action congress is now taking she
had previously stated
that articles of impeachment will be
introduced immediately
if the president refuses to resign from
office he can only pardon himself from
federal offenses he cannot pardon
himself from state offenses and that's
where
he's being investigated in the state of
new york well i like
the 25th amendment because it gets rid
of him he's
out of office but there is strong
support
in the congress for impeaching the
president a second time